May God’s peace, mercy, and blessings be upon you. Oh God, may
you all be well. How do I protect my Facebook account,
even if someone has your
password? Ok, let us go into the explanation. The first thing you must do is create your own phone number on Facebook, and of course most of us have this phone number activated. We will enter
from the part on the right.  Here, if you have Facebook in
Arabic, it remains on the left and we go to
Setting. After that, we will enter the part of the
mobile phone to see the number that is registered,
or we can say in Arabic, mobile phones. I will find that
the part above is hidden here because the
two numbers are in my phone number and
another number. You will go even if  Here, there are no
phone numbers. You will enter a number. Try to be 100% sure that
this number will remain with you, because one of the things
that has happened in the recent period is that
mobile companies stop, for example, your line and sell it
to another person, and you keep the link to this phone number
in your account, so it is possible for the person who bought the
phone number to recover the password.  Through the
phone number, we will go and add a phone number. If we do not have
it, he will tell you where you are. For example, in
Saudi Arabia, we write the phone number, which is “such and such,” and I
do a “Contino.” He tells me this number
exists before. Once he sends me the number, he will take me to a
second page, which tells me to write the code.
It comes to you on your mobile phone. As soon as I write the
code, this number will be activated. This is one of the numbers that
belong to me. This is the first step. The second step is that we will go to the
security. The first time I enter the security, I will find something
called log proof. I go to it and it will
say, “You want to log proof for
your account from any strange browser or device.”  Of course, I will teach you
about it. The first teacher who tells me how it works is that if someone
tries to log in from a device other than yours
or a browser, it will send you a proof log on your mobile phone. After you
write this proof or the code
that comes to you, you have a problem with your account, I started started, and he
tells me that you did not use this thing, a
generator code. I will tell you about it later.  Contino
As soon as I did Contino, it tells
me that I will send you a text or SMS on your mobile phone. Write the code here. I will wait for my mobile phone to come. The
SMS will come. You heard that in a message I received a code that will consist of about six numbers, and this is the code that came here. It confirms that
the code  It's okay. I do a content. I didn't do a
content. He tells me that if you enter a stranger's browser, he
will ask you for the code. And for the first week, if you don't have your phone, try turning off the
Date feature so you know how to worry about your account. I will tell him, "Okay, close
like that." It's okay. He activated the SMS service
so I can enter.  On my account, okay. He is now
telling me that there are two hidden phone numbers here.
As soon as I log into the account, he
sends me an SMS. Where are these? Okay, let’s try entering another browser like this. Write my username,
phone number, or email to access my
account. Do a login now.  A person with me has the
user name and I have the password of
one person. I tried to log in as you can see. He tells
me that there are six numbers that come to you on the mobile phone. You must write them down so that you can enter the account. Ok, I did not get the code that is supposed to come to the mobile phone.
What should I do? I type in the receiver
code and make a text message.  The code is:
Send me an SMS with the login code. As soon as I
click on it, it will tell me, Okay, we have sent
you something on your mobile. We hear that now. I am getting an SMS with the six-digit
code. I will
lock this and write the numbers that came to me. Okay. Just
write. It tells me.  Okay, I
entered. I want to use the browser you are entering from,
so that when you enter it later, it does
not ask you for codes, nor are you entering a temporary password. I
will say “Saif,” for example, and do a “Continue” that is fine, and now I am logged
in to my account, fine, and with that, I have
activated the feature. Ok, there is another way I can
access it.  My account without him sending
me an SMS. This means that, for example, the service can be
stopped at any capacity. Will the world stop? I
will not be able to enter the account. No, there is no need. Also, if you have a
smart phone or Android and open your Facebook, you will also
go to the part on the
right of the phone.  Sorry, I'm
not taking pictures of the topic right now. On your phone
and scroll down,
you will find something called a generator code.
Once you click on it, it will
tell you that you have activated the service. You say to it, "Oh, you have activated," and it will show you a
six-digit code that you can use at any time. The
picture is in front of you from your mobile phone. I hope that he will.
May God make the lesson simple. Sorry, I feel
like I was too long for you. I mean, I just tried to explain
everything in detail. Thank you. If you like the video, don’t
forget to share the video and like so
that people can
benefit. Protect your accounts. Peace be upon you.